salud en directo a América de Francia 24
y está con nosotros en el estudio Marina
sardina Marina bienvenida buena mañana
de lunes vamos a iniciar esta semana con
un estudio publicado por el British
Medical journal que analizó la evolución
global de la diabetes tipo 2 esto en
adolescentes y jóvenes durante
1990 y 1991 los resultados apuntan a que
la prevalencia este tipo de diabetes
aumentó ocasión 60% en sólo un año
no en los últimos 30 en los últimos 1990
hasta el 2019 Y es que son unos datos
que asombran porque el grupo poblacional
del que trata este estudio va entre los
15 años a los 39 años unas edades en las
que la diabetes pues no está tan
propensa a desarrollarse en esta en
estas edades los datos preocupan como
decimos porque en solo 30 años las
diabetes tipo 2 incrementó un 60 por
ciento la diabetes tipo 2 recordemos se
asocia con una mayor duración de la
hiperglucemia y un proceso más rápido
del proceso patológico incluida la
resistencia a la insulina el principal
factor de riesgo atribuible hasta
aumento es el inicio temprano de
obesidad y sobrepeso que como recordemos
se potencia debido a hábitos poco
saludables dietas ricas en carnes rojas
y procesadas alimentos
ultraprocesados altos en azúcares que
agravan esta enfermedad que también está
relacionada con el acceso que tienen las
personas a una dieta saludable y
nutritiva por lo que son los jóvenes
también de ingresos de países de
ingresos medios y bajos los que tienen
las tasas más altas de esta dolencia
Crónica esto sumado a los cambios de
vida en las últimas décadas la
contaminación o el tabaquismo a edad
temprana también ayudan al desarrollo de
esta enfermedad y son algunos de los
factores de riesgo no solo entre la
población joven sino también entre los
en todo el mundo hay más de 537
de adultos que viven con diabetes solo
en 2021 Y es que también el índice de
masa corporal alto alto según este
estudio fue el principal contribuyente a
la carga de diabetes tipo 2 y del inicio
temprano a este aumento mundial desde
1990 Raúl Marina este aumento también
tiene mucho que ver en el género y la
clase social cierto Así es una vez más
volvemos a las desigualdades
socioeconómicas de los países que se ven
agravadas en nuestra salud no también
las poblaciones siendo estas poblaciones
de países más empobrecidos las que
tienen índices más altos de esta
enfermedad pero que lo Respecto a los
países de altos ingresos que no están
excluidos de estos números que están
aumentando el estudio por primera vez
también pone de manifiesto algo muy
novedoso como las desigualdades de
género que están relacionadas con las
tasas de diabetes las mujeres menores de
30 años que tienen una calidad de vida
más baja se relacionan con índices más
altos de diabetes tipo 2 con su
mortalidad o discapacidad por esta
enfermedad esto es debido en parte al
acceso limitado a los diagnósticos de
seguimiento atención médica de las
mujeres que viven estos países de bajos
ingresos que tienen como decimos un
acceso muy limitado por ejemplo al
control de la glucemia incluso durante
el embarazo Esto es lo que dice el
informe al respecto
sospechamos que el embarazo y el
síndrome de ovario poliquístico en
mujeres que están asociados con la
resistencia a la insulina podrían
contribuir en parte a las diferencias
entre sexos también encontramos que la
mayor carga de enfermedad en las mujeres
era más pronunciada en los países con un
índice sodio demográfico bajo que en uno
alto este hallazgo podría deberse a que
en los países menos desarrollados las
niñas y las mujeres pueden tener a menos
acceso a los servicios de atención
médica y una peor salud metabólica que
los niños y los hombres incluido el
control de la glucemia un control
glucémico deficiente durante el período
reproductivo común en las mujeres es
decir edad menor de 30 años podría
causar hiperglucemia en el embarazo y
resultados adversos para la descendencia
y este es un llamado una vez más a las
autoridades sanitarias de todos los
países a tomar esta enfermedad Como un
tema de salud pública cuyas causas y
factores pues radica la medida radica el
tener medidas específicas para hacer
frente a esta problemática y sin embargo
no todo es negativo las medidas puestas
por muchos estados Como por ejemplo los
impuestos a los cigarrillos o La
regulación de la calidad del aire han
demostrado ser efectivas en cuanto a
esta enfermedad Marina y vamos a hablar
ahora de china porque ahí se preparan
para el aumento de contagios de covid-19
esto por qué debido a los millones de
viajes que van a ser las personas
internamente que se van a realizar en
estas fechas por el año nuevo lunar Así
es Raúl seguimos hablando de covid
porque los últimos datos que ofreció el
gobierno chino estiman que casi 60.000
muertos por covid en China desde inicios
de diciembre hasta el 12 de enero estos
son los últimos datos ofrecidos también
que sean han estado pedidos por todas
las organizaciones y también por la
Organización Mundial de la salud Un
aumento con respecto a las cifras
anteriores que como decimos Fueron
criticadas por la MS por no reflejar la
escala y la gravedad del brote ahora la
Organización Mundial de la Salud acogió
estos datos con gratificación pero pidió
un desglose más detallado por provincias
Y es que algunos expertos pronostican
que las muertes eran de más de un millón
Durante este año las cifras señalan
también que más del 80% murieron por
problemas subyacentes complicados por la
infección de covid enfermedades previas
como pues enfermedades cardiovasculares
o respiratorias pero excluyen a personas
que mueren en el hogar específicamente
en área rural Rurales con sistemas
médicos más débiles por lo que las
autoridades chinas están enfocando en
reforzar precisamente estos centros de
salud de los de las zonas Rurales
enviando suministros médicos oxígeno
para paliar la crisis Esto es lo que
dijeron las autoridades chinas
desde 2020 china siempre ha insistido en
clasificar las muertes con un resultado
positivo en la prueba de ácido nucleico
como muerte relacionados con covid este
criterio coincide en gran medida con el
de la Organización Mundial de la Salud y
otros países importantes hay dos
categorías de causas de muerte una es
insuficiencia respiratoria debido a la
infección por covid y la otra es la
infección por covid combinada con otras
enfermedades subyacentes
Gracias por toda la información de salud
mañana con más mañana más mañana